hey everybody and welcome to gamespot's
live stream of Sniper Elite 3 do you
guys hear really loud K-pop right now
because the studio is filled with
loud went away okay I really hope that
you guys could hear that K-pop on the
stream because that might have been a
little psychological Terror on the part
of video producers trying to throw us
off to be fair it could have been Jpop
yeah yeah I think we held that intro
together like a couple of Champs we are
professionals unlike the ensuing stream
that we're about to take part in of
Sniper Elite 3 yeah a game that comes
out quite soon pretty soon yeah uh Chris
Waters Sean mckinness tell me what you
know about sniping just in general it's
when you have a gun that's pretty long
okay and then you point it at some
people who are not close to you oh God
what's happening why is that that thing
is on fire I feel like you should stay
next to it oh no it's just making some
noise okay uh so you have this long gun
there's people who are far away from you
and you try to shoot them with your long
gun yes that is correct I'm I'm pretty
Elite when it comes to sniper and
knowledge I'm looking through this uh
collector's edition 10 of we going to
bust that thing out already nice all
right so
judging by
this the trick is to shoot the man in
one of several vital locations
face yep that's one of them the heart y
or this region number 15 yeah good old
number 15 as I like to call it the old
number 15 that is actually the highest
value points on that on that sheet
exactly cuz crotch shots because crotch
shots so uh Sniper Elite 3 obviously set
in World War II but perhaps not the most
popular or well trod of World War II
locations the Ain no Market Garden this
ain't no Market Garden this ain't no uh
Omaha this
is Africa Africa Africa Africa I'm going
to snipe an elite dude okay or I'm snip
Elite him are you the Elite Sniper or
are you sniping Elite men no I'm doing
the Elite Sniper okay let's see
let's I okay that was a bad shot you
wounded him in the butt but now I just
alerted him oh oh shot through the heart
and you're too blame okay I got to go
away from you give you give love a bad
name um this is the second this is the
second uh level okay so I'm you're still
going to see some of that uh all right I
got to go a little faster all right now
tell me how familiar are you with Sniper
Elite a franchise yeah I uh I reviewed
Sniper Elite V2
gamespot.com so uh quite quite familiar
uh it's a game about sniping mhm so yeah
you got you got to like you have you you
have your submachine gun you have your
silence pistol which you use in your
your Close Quarters combat you just saw
that but you know the the sort of the
main attraction is those bullet cam uh
eviscerating shots that you just saw m
where you get real real good
appreciation for human anatomy destroyed
that you do such as a moment ago when we
saw a bullet pierce through a man's
heart yeah that was pretty vicious in
thorough detail all right so yeah right
now I'm just kind of sneaking around
trying to find some good snip all
positions and uh is this there are like
these places on the map that you can
find there called sniper nests I'm going
to look at the map if I yeah I'm not
close to a sniper no you're not Nest
where am I I need to find information
about the base it looks like I just like
waltzed right by
it I'm slightly confused but whatever
the trick is that you haven't shot
enough men in the heads oh I definitely
have not I that guy is alarmed what what
what need to shoot him before he gets
too alarmed no he just found the dead
guy that I shot oh yeah don't worry
buddy now you're not shooting like a
silenced sniper rifle here you are
shooting a gun that produces noise and
these men will hear it and get alarmed
yeah they sure will uh but that won't
stop me from trying to shoot them in
their testicles shoot him right shoot
him in the junk oh no we might have one
here folks I don't know this is
definitely going to hit oh just going to
oh there it
is oh we got a little femur action good
night sweet prince wow oh something to
collect there we go that man will never
sire a child he just said something to
collect from this corpse what are you
going to collect I'll tell the
eviscerated remains of his testies I'll
tell you what he's not going to collect
that's I mean if I had to guess maybe
Sniper Elite is just uh you know he's a
he's a fan of uh biology I'm just going
sorry are you referring to the
protagonist of Sniper Elite 3 as Sniper
Elite that's not his name I thought his
name was Sniper
Elite no I think it's Steve Elite Steve
Elite yeah people think the S stands for
Sniper and he's happy to let them
believe that I'm going to go collect
this man's shattered
genitalia H okay that's probably a good
idea right yeah no I totally all right
totally think so so where if you guys
are uh watching this live on twitch.tv/
Gamespot feel free to jump into the chat
and we'll uh ask any questions that you
might have or in the uh comments of the
Gamespot live stream we should
theoretically have a live chat going on
games.com but it's still in the early
stages yet so it might not be 100%
functional but we're working on it okay
where's this going to go I was aiming
for the crotch again were are you are we
going to see another oh wow wow yeah you
are just now do they die when you shoot
off their penises or are they just like
forever shamed no look this guy yeah I'm
going to just search his corpse real
quick what am I going to find oh a note
a a map you know what I didn't find what
intact genitalia no he most certainly
did not if that man ever had intact
genitalia he certainly does not have it
anymore see the sniper the for the
sniper is not just to destroy his
enemies in the short term it's to
destroy the it's to [__] the
reproductive power of the enemy Nation
yeah you don't want like German
scientists coming along and collecting
these men's reproductive organs and then
fusing them onto robot cyborgs and
creating a master race of German robots
with penises I mean that's a very real
possibility that is a threat that Sniper
Elite thinks about every waking day of
his life I feel like I'm danger close to
these guys cuz uh you know the flashing
triangle whatever so I'm playing on
normal
difficulty
uh that that like indicator up the top
means I can shoot someone and they won't
hear the noise uh normal diff like
sniper Rel the thing here is like there
is a really pretty broad swath of
difficulty levels so that you can play a
super unforgiving like with unforgiving
bullet physics and uh you know like Drop
and that bullet drop and that whole uh
what do you call it that like zoom in
Focus mode thing that I had going on
there a second ago you just wouldn't
have any of that but I am not that good
at this game no don't sell yourself
short I want to show you guys dramatic
shots and therefore I am not going to
try this that mode instead we're going
to get down in here a little bit do some
stealthy bits Sean you're continuing to
look through the I'm looking through
this collector's edition of Sniper Elite
3 Africa uhhuh there is uh as we saw the
uh the targeting thing and now we see
this uh this old timey advertisement for
Isis the queen of Cairo and a whole
bunch of what is that some kind of lady
yeah lady dancer jafar's club and then
you have various different maps and such
Mediterranean Sea I'm sure that you guys
can see this in in very high
detail at the bottom of the screen uh
I'm actually I'm just fascinated by
what's in here I'm looking for
Collectibles and hanging out right next
to a giant fire snip as well you should
are we giving away one of these no or is
this just oh okay I thought we were
doing this as a giveway no we're showing
them the stuff that's in it okay I think
we need this for review purposes oh well
uh well H Chris waters on Twitter I'm
sure that if you do it enough he'll give
you something yeah it may not be the
game maybe he'll just like send you a
nice picture or a please stop messaging
M he might just block
you um bam now back to Sniper Elite 3
yeah did you see that head shot I just
did no I didn't I got a ghost kill bonus
I got a tagged kill I got a head shot
bonus I'm getting so many XPS man I'm
stacking them XPS now as we can see
Sniper Elite does not have to use a
sniper rifle to kill anybody no Sniper
Elite can use a handgun if he so chooses
yeah he uh he can also use a submachine
gun when he gets into a tight spot okay
but I actually want to try something uh
over here that let's see I want these
guys to like go away for a
second all right hold on there's a way
to use dynamite oh yeah you going to
Chuck it at that dude
I whatever you're doing right now is the
wrong thing to do I am very exposed yeah
you are super oh so you planted some
dynamite and now you're going to make
some noise and you're going to lure the
guy over here and then you're going to
remotely detonate The Dynamite by
shooting it with your handgun you got it
buddy all right well I'm probably I
don't know if I'm going to shoot it with
my handgun we'll
see think that sniper Flint steel oh
yeah I started a fire there that's cool
all right okay you got this homie okay
all right you got this
all right here's my
Dynamite shoot it yet I'm waiting well
they're supposed to be like do you throw
a rock can you throw a rock over there I
can no but see the fire started now oh
right now they're going to come
investigate yeah see that yellow that's
one I'm hoping for two I'm fishing for
two come on come on over buddy oh no the
other guy's not coming he's walking
away oh [__] that was a terrible
shot okay we have word bad decision oh
oh got him okay sick I got him that was
good although we don't get the slow
motion uh explosion death you know what
it might have been because I did a bad
job yeah you probably I mean you bungled
that one let's be honest with ourselves
defitely did but in the end you got your
man and isn't that what matters most for
Sniper Elite uh-oh uh-oh did he see me
no he didn't see me oh yeah they saw me
okay okay so it's got like a last known
position mechanic
yeah all right this guy's going to pop
his head out at some point and then
you're going to shoot
him seems that seems like a good
plan come on come on move shoot this guy
move whoa he's on the Run who he is come
on step God
Diggity all right he's he's moving too
quick he's a crafty one fine I'm I'm
going to move I'm going to relocate what
is this hot off the presses news you're
holding all right so if you're watching
this on Gamespot you can refresh and you
will get the the chat room sweet yeah so
if you want to do that I'm going to do
that right now and I've got the chat
room in
here the chat server isn't responding
right now please be patient okay well
I'm going to try totient I'm going to
get over here and I'm going to Sniper
Elite this guy and then we
can oh
yeah okay so what does it mean when it
says relocation successful
uh so basically when once I've been uh
you know once I've sort of caught the
attention of these guys can I go
prone is that slow down time or just yes
so that's like a focus mode I'm pressing
R1 to slow down time I think I'm going
to get this guy in the hip oh oh right
in the spa oh whatever that intestine
situation is oh God ow intin shot yeah
all right y's he's going to feel that
one in the morning I guarantee you that
he's going to feel nothing no oh what I
don't want to do okay I pressed the
wrong button and I started a fire I
think there's a guy right over
here this is this is a bad
scene no do not use binoculars at this
juncture I think I can oh nope he's
around the
corner that is uh that is what happens
when Sniper Elite gets pushed into a
corner he will fight back like a vicious
tiger he's not always going to use his
sniper rifle sometimes he'll go at you
with a submachine gun yeah sometimes
Sniper Elite has to get real nasty yeah
the thing about Sniper Elite is that he
he does whatever is necessary he has his
own code of conduct also I just threw a
rock in the place that I'm actively
walking to which was maybe not the
smartest move well it's like a reverse
bread breadcrumb
Trail reverse breadcrumb Trail yeah you
are instead of leaving a path from where
you've been you're leaving a path of
where you're going that's true so that
you don't get lost let's meet there yeah
meet
there okay are these guys going to come
over to my rock
situation I'm not sure you got this uh
all right so you see it says all clear
in the bottom left there the eyes sort
of uh indicates that I'm not being seen
these are the feedback meters you get on
normal mode in Sniper Elite 3 that like
you know it sort of
gets you with the
uh teaches shows you the stuff you need
to know in terms of managing your
exposure M so when like I said when a
shot is fired your alert meter goes up
uh then you have to relocate and if you
relocate enough then your alert meter
goes down and then they're just res the
guards resume normal Patrol there's a
couple different tiers of like alert
meters over the guard's heads the yellow
is them just sort of searching the red
is like oh my God we know where this gu
at we got to we got to get
him uh and so you want to avoid the Reds
and the yellows preferably I'm working
my way around this bowl here to get over
to a sniper perch which I saw on the map
um and you can see also on screen is
like the BPM your heart rate so like if
I if I walk like this my heart rate's
going to go up got it um and then that's
going to make sniping harder right cuz
you're a little more jittery if you if
you if you've been sprinting for like
clear across the map and then you set
down and you go to snipe somebody you're
probably going to be
all I'm having such a hard time seeing
oh my goodness all right let's put a
land mine there which like I don't yeah
you're definitely not going to come back
and accidentally walk over that how that
happened uh it just went away okay
wasn't even on there I want to see a
super gruesome stealth kill the stealth
kills aren't terribly gruesome there's
just that you just ripped his throat out
you ripped that man's throat out and
threw him callously from a cliff I sure
did wow that is a real uh that's worse
than they found that body down there so
they're probably going to get a little
I'm going to enter a sniper Nest yeah o
this is not conspicuous all right Sniper
Elite in his natural habitat now I can
uh reproduce and create new
snipers wait what it's a sniper Nest is
that why you've been collecting all
those eviscerated testicles yes sniper
physiology is mysterious to many but uh
you know today we're going to learn a
thing or two so I feel like if you shoot
that guy the dude at the fire is going
to hear you right a lot of dudes are
going to hear me there's like a ton of
dudes around here there's a dude right
below this platform it's like really not
a great idea can you do the thing where
you put a potato at the end of your gun
and that becomes a
silencer I mean I guess I could I feel
like you should try it I feel like I
should sabotage
this
I don't uh yeah I don't I thought that
was going to like make noise so that
they wouldn't hear me really I just
kicked it and I kicked it over all right
so you're saying I should kill sleepy
guy here before I kill that shoot him
because the bullet's not going to whiz
by him or it's not going to all right
let's bam wow that was ter he got up
he's fine whoa what' you shoot I don't
know I think there was probably like a
barrel behind him I think that guy might
have had a Grenade on his oh you shot
his grenade that was a sick double kill
this is they are all alerted yeah oh
yeah big
time okay I'm going to shoot some of
these circles why not is this going to
nope oh
God okay they fell okay I'm in a bad
situation all right weapons
loud feather the trigger there you go
short controlled bursts that's what
Sniper Elite learned at the sniper
Academy
all right what am I where are my Gren
where's my granatas
at all right I got two grenades should
be okay I should be okay I'm I'm going
to survive this I keep looking back and
thinking there's a ghost following you
like it's a metaphor for how Sniper
Elite is like just haunted by his
memories yeah that happens everywhere he
goes and that's why he be became this
ruthless killer mhm it's a metaphor for
his motivations hoping to kill oh
there's a guy coming up there is I'm
going to hide in this bush it will not
be effective no no it'll work try to try
to oh there's another man behind you
oh Sniper Elite I wonder if they shot me
in my dick I I feel like we should have
seen a a slow motion Camp eliminate the
officer from the sniper
Nest all right going to the sniper Nest
just didn't
I the problem is that you shot the wrong
dude problem is that I like maybe if I
just
shoot oh yeah I got to shoot that
officer that's what I got to do come
here look at you where do you want me to
shoot the
officer uh should we go for a head shot
let me use a visual aid okay I want you
to off show me on the diagram where I
should shoot the
officer right here in his upside down
crotch in his upside down penis all
right you got that you got it buddy make
it happen Chris there you go I feel like
that is roughly where a penis is nope
nope if anything you mortally wounded
his
penis uh-oh I'm relocate I did not kill
that guy finish the job I got him I got
him I didn't finish the job no cuz it it
said kill okay all
right have these guys died from
landmines yet that was a real messy one
you could have you could have been a
little bit more clean with that I was
trying to shoot him in his you know you
you called the shot and I didn't get him
in the number
15 oh no oh
no there you go you got 5 x I going to
step on a land mine
probably okay this is a bad scene I need
to like uh if people in the chat room
are wondering what difficulty level
you're on you are on normal difficulty
I'm on super not difficult yeah and
that's why I mean it's it says a fair
challenge yeah oh what that star is
still there oh no I have to
search so okay so now do you have to go
to the dead officer and search him yes I
do okay but see all right so you see
they're searching the the bar is full
they've completed their search my
relocation is successful determined
there's no more threat and they're going
to carry on don't worry guys it's cool
it's cool we'll be just just
fine I'm going to go hide in this hole
which is not good for sniping but it is
good for being whole it is good for
being out of sight and out of mind which
is part of what sniper Elite's mission
is I'm not like the most elite of
snipers don't sell yourself short Sean
You're Building me up I keep tearing
myself down you build me back up I
really appreciate buddy oh God
uh-oh about to get hot
somebody's going to get shot in the
number 15 and it might not be the
Germans it might be you might be me it
might be
you they're going to try to flush me
out I think that I need to have my mp 40
out okay they're going to the end of
that
tunnel that comes down the tunnel you
know what's going to happen they're
going to shoot his dick clean off
just clean off uhoh
Jesus I'm making a real hash of this you
are oh
hey all right they're coming you got to
you got to get out of here going into
this tiny trench in the ground was
apparently not the smooth smoothest idea
make a run for
it old move but El elite elite come on
Sniper Elite you can do this back up to
the sniper perch they'll never expect it
they'll never expect it it's all the
half of being a sniper is playing head
games there's the ghost of your former
self yeah that's wow that's the ghost of
me being a stealthy sniper dude they are
shooting my
ghost Germans were incredibly
superstitious in this time and they
believed if you shot a man's ghost you
could kill him
yeah also if you carve a runnel through
his lung oh then you are able to kill
him
yoes all right
uh they're looking for
me oh [__] damn
it don't get
killed there you
go
yikes now is there a finite number of
enemies on a given map or do they keep
sending in reinforcements so you can
like just very slowly clear out an
entire level yeah or like slowly at
first but then a little B more
frantically cuz you're not doing a good
job and then you know a little bit more
slowly once you get your [__]
together there you
go I'm just
really what did he just say come on
translate that he said holy [__] some
dude is shooting us yeah he said
everybody guard your penises there's a
man out for everybody's number 15 he
said I'm throwing a grenade maybe no
dang na it all
right so if I shoot the officer from the
sniper Nest uhuh like all these dudes
get super pissed but I feel like there's
a reason there's a sniper Nest here with
a clear line of sight towards that
officer and it's I I I failed to hit him
in the number 15 last time go for you
might have hit him in the number 14 last
time really focus on what makes 15 15
going for the Dome we're going to see
some we're going to see some some
cranial structure
here
oh see there you go now get out of here
get out of here cuz they know that's
where you where you've been that is the
benefit of
uh shooting the face is there's a lot
more bones there as opposed to the
metaphorical bone that is at the number
15 oh yeah no that guy sees me that
guy's over there see that's the thing
like the you you mean that's the
downside of the sniper perch yeah is it
there's no exit from it but I'm all
clear so maybe they're
just see they don't like they don't see
my ghost I feel like because they don't
see my ghost they don't come here
specifically
so let's try to spot some
dudes tag that guy yeah
try to you got this here I'm gonna tag
this guy if I tag him do you mean shoot
him no I mean put a tiny carrot over his
head and say I'll see you I'll save you
for
later oh what's that that's an explosive
item that's some Dynomite yeah but if
you shoot it you can create a
distraction and then sneak on
by Perfect plan Sean I like your plan
let's give it a shot all right here we
go shoot the red box feel like I'm
danger all right I have all right all
right oh that guy's going to get
it yeah you're going to get it buddy
shoot him shoot him in the well should I
shoot him and then I mean I'm I'm I'm
shooting the box right that's the
experiment yeah okay yeah you should do
that shoot the
Box heyo a
relocate expion wasn't nuts they saw me
no I think it was because so I think
that triangle was the key
okay
and yep that guy well he saw me but I'm
I'm going to be
okay relocation successful so I think as
long as I don't
have oh [__] I'm just going to I'm just
going to take a shot over at these guys
real
quick you checking a grenade from
downtown oh Sher oh triple
kill pretty good not bad yeah that was
good that was pretty Sniper Elite what
is it oh tagged I thought it said
toggled Tagg makes sense yeah 15 M 14
met who's that close to me not that guy
surely not that
guy six me I feel like I feel like I'm
trouble I feel I should got this you got
this who is 6 MERS away though like
where even is that guy oh some guy who's
about to get his junk ruined
is who's 6 M away from you you get 6 M
within Sniper Elite and I guarantee you
you might survive but you're going to
survive with no remaining junk yeah
you're going to have no junk left you're
just going to shoot it clean off it's
going to be gone it's it'll be like you
never had junk to begin with full sever
like it'll fall off fully cauterized and
justly cauterized yeah it'll just be
lying on the ground you'll be in agony
but you won't bleed out from that oh
yeah you'll be fine that's the the
pinpoint Precision of Sniper
Elite surgical surgical might say yeah
he's a surgeon of War but like really
focused on penis amputations yeah what
how's this guy looking at me why you
looking at me through a through a tent I
think I think you know what you have to
do throw a rock over there lure him over
you are really big on the Rock throwing
yeah man all right I'm done with that
lure him over
there what do you want stab or well Rod
which is my silence pistol well Rod not
to be confused well Rod this dude that's
your silence pistol yeah that's TI
pretty much sucks oh that was a pretty
good shot that was a baller
shot that was clean that was classic
Sniper Elite that's what he trained to
do back in
Langley I assume he trained in
Langley Langley Langley yeah sure right
that seems like a place where Spooks
train he's uh he's Sniper
Elite he was in the CIA before he joined
British Special Forces he joined the
elite yeah of sniper
dummy going to go oh he's just right
there is he on the other side of that
rock no I can't tell oh slow down oh
yeah it slows down like my aim but it
doesn't slow down those guys moving
around and stuff oh okay so you're not
manipulating time no just space come on
uh I don't want to
throw is this this is a rock this is a
rock you see how fast I throw a rock oh
yeah I'm real good at Ro that's one of
the things they teach you back in
Langley how to Chuck a rock how to Chuck
a rock real good all right this guy's
asking on the move I got it lined up oh
incapacitation oh oh that one's going to
go oh you shot an incapacitated man
death from below right in the veg
and right the what I was going to say
meat and to veg but I I butchered it
okay I messed it up me and to veg meat
and to veg that is some food groups yeah
right in the food groups
yeah all
right those guys are searching over
there I don't want to get into a bad
situation wow there's a lot of them why
do you guys all just run run over there
I can grenade the crap out of you again
get another triple kill you can do this
how far can you Chuck a grenade pretty
pretty far I bet you could chuck a
grenade over that
mountain do it from down down wow whoa I
got one of them that was a hell
marry did uh did Sniper Elite play
quarterback on his high school football
team oh man he he was recruited for the
minor league
leagues come here come here bad guys you
got
this all right CHR how do you feel about
taking a brief break one more one more
15 attempt before we take a break okay a
come on Lucky Number
15 nope just the femur we did get good
look we got a real good look oh man so
that's what they look
like Oh that's oh okay cool all right
and so with that we're going to take a
very brief commercial break but stay
tuned we'll be right
back and we are back Chris Waters
continues his campaign of Terror against
the Germans in North Africa here in
Sniper Elite 3 we're playing the
PlayStation 4 version of the game which
comes out very soon I think I want to
say July 1st depending on your
region let's see it probably says on gam
Spot
somewhere
boom yeah this game's out like next
week my yeah comes out July 1st or if
you're in the European Union June
27th search this guys corpse what am I
going to find crap that
dude
all right you got this where am I going
to aim if this guy comes up shoot him in
the head I think we've we've been going
a little too deep into 15 territory
lately is he I think he's behind that Ro
no he's probably exposed oh yeah you got
this we're in the neck that's a that's a
Topper that's a scalp job oh through the
bushes oh
no o those
are Grim they are I feel like they would
be less Grim if you didn't see his
eyeballs his eyeballs cuz the eyeballs
you can you can really look into their
state of emotions like are they
surprised that they have a bullet pet
their head is going through their skull
is it a look of resignation you can you
can read a lot of emotions based is it
relief is it relief that they're that
they this torturous life is over for
them
finally all clear all clear for some
reason
you're all right doing okay I'm doing
okay I don't want to get spotted I so
once again your
goal at the moment is to make your way
across the map to collect the Intel from
the officer that you shot before is that
what we're trying to do and then there's
two more officers that I need to shoot
oh boy yeah all right we're going to do
this Chris we got this I believe in me I
mean on the plus side right there use
your uh your little uh I feel like I
need to try to stealth kill him your
littley low on baby gun you should use
your little Tic Tac going to take take
too long there you
go that was sick how you mantled the
[__] out of that I want you to have more
silenced ammo on you but you have a med
kit instead that might come in handy you
never know yeah I mean based on some of
my earlier performance it definitely
might but this game it seems like it
does have regenerating Health though
doesn't it no I patched myself up other
times that I was yeah no it I don't
think it has regenerating Health cuz
like you can you choose your load out
ahead of time M and um one of the things
you can choose is a medkit which uh
replenishes like three bars of health
and one is a bandage which just
replenishes two is your health at yellow
stage okay got
it all right I'm going to go over here I
previously shot this
Commander and now I have to go loot his
corpse for valuable
Intel and also balls are intact the
Intel is going to be a note that says
beware of snipers on the sniper
perch I don't know why we built that
thing I it was a bad
idea flies are already around this guy
or they might not be flies you shot this
guy in the head right or was it the
junk I'm
glad we lose more sure that's good Intel
you can take that back to Langley I
could SWA my well rod for a Luger but
the Luger is not silenced I didn't do
that
so I'm going to keep my well Rod now the
well
Rod is your silenced handun my lay ass
silence sandgun yes no it it seems like
that thing has been pretty handy
actually you are disparaging the well
Rod when I say lame I mean it's like you
can't it's not like one of the I I
actually mean it's probably actually can
I swim nope I think that's death that is
one thing that is beyond the
capabilities of Sniper Elite uh the man
not the game yeah uh when I say lame I
mean like there are other games like
like Sam Fisher like Solid Snake these
guys can shoot people on a pinpoint head
shot with a silence pistol from like 50
m away or something crazy uh Sniper
Elite cannot do that soly is a man bound
to the fickle nature of physics yeah
yeah he is we don't have physics like
super keyed in right now uh CU that's
you can sort of on see oh you can't
change the difficulty from here but we
we'll check that once I finished this
level so is it like on a harder
difficulty ballistic physics are more of
a factor yeah physics are more of a
factor and you just get less indicators
and sort of assists uh to help you in
your in your struggle eliminate the
officer from the sniper Nest all right I
just need to I need to start shooting
some people again i' I've had a bit of a
drought here uh which is fine it's all
good for the mission can I this actually
yeah let's do that let's just save the
game real quick oh yeah yeah little Mid
Mission save they have pretty good Auto
checkpoints as you guys probably saw
earlier when I died but um I saw
dude so you can do this like this
marking stuff I'm sure that's not their
unauthentic stuff and I'm curious to
know if anyone in the chat if you guys
have played these games uh do you do you
relish any kind of intense challenge
have you really ramped it up the few
times I've tried to do that it's it's
just been an exercise and like really
patience is the toughest thing yeah uh
that you have to like really double down
on so just overcoming your own lack of
patience yeah totally all right I'm
going to this seems like a real wild
card move yeah I I want to try some
stunt some stunt fun shots but uh I
don't I'm not exact there's trees and
stuff so I'm just going to keep going
this way a little
bit so currently you are going
those those two icons on the mini map in
the bottom the two white icons there're
two commanders there that I need to kill
and and search their bodies for some
notes they're not displayed on screen
right now but I think I can tap the
touch pad on the we're playing PS4 by
the way can tap the touchpad and see
them now Sniper Elite 3 also available
on the following platform
PlayStation 3 Xbox 360 Xbox One and the
Microsoft Windows personal computer what
do you want here Sean head or like torso
I I feel like head is the guaranteed
kill right oh it definitely is right in
the ear hole
oh oh yaa so
they they definitely have the
uh like bone shattering stuff like
really double down on that
but not so much the soft materials yet
yeah like you don't see the brain
actually exploding
yeah it's going to cost them how do
those how do those shots compare to
Sniper Elite V2 uh there seems to be
much more fragmentation yeah
um what I'm hiding behind a freaking
wall he can't see me he just knows that
this is where a dead person was or
is can you check a rocket
him that was a bad idea that was a my
bad
oh making a bit of a hash of this it's
fine first I got to take this guy
out nope I thought I switched weapons
but I didn't oh [__] time to get the
hell out of here oh that was a bad idea
I really sabotaged you on that one
that's fine I'm just going to go back
through my prone hole your prone hole
Yeah I I might not even need to go as
far as my prone
hole get to the prone hole you got to
pay the prone toll to get into this
prone
hole here we go there we go it'll never
find me there you go right back into the
prone hole from Once you came going to
do an end
around
yeah it's all about playing head games
got to circle around it is now it's
going to be about playing ball games I
keep getting confused by the fact that
no matter which gun you have equipped
there's always a rock icon in the bottom
right so I keep thinking that the well
Rod is the name of your rock no my the
name of my rock is Chuck Chuck Chuck the
rock yeah all right look I'm going to
learn I'm going to learn about this dude
he's suspicious are you watch dogging
that guy yeah I just watch dog that dude
all right all right now shoot him in the
heart all right that looks like roughly
where a human heart would
be oh oh got the lung long oh no it was
a hard shot there you go sweet nice work
a I'm so proud of
me do you have any indicator of how many
enemies are remaining unless you've like
actually gone around and tagged
everybody no I don't think
so
here those guys are far enough away that
you could shoot one of them I think I
can shoot both of them
oh come on I want them to line up I want
to get a
twofer got
this he's it going to
be a fireside chat guy
maybe go for the balls yeah go for the
junk oh feel pretty confident in that
one uh it's going to be at least pelvis
might be that oh it's going to be
yeah oh oh
wow 45 experience
points oh stick your tiny head
up got it you got this oh oh
yeah just chaining them back and forth
right through the P helmet and out to
the other side see it's the eyeballs
it's being able to see the eyeball
eyeballs all right I know you want he's
he's going to poke poke his little face
out
part oh oh oh [__] oh dang had that I
had my your heart rate is climbing by
the way yeah well I was I was like
holding my breath oh so this must be the
only other guy left in this area
otherwise all right I think I'm going to
hit him if I yeah all right that's going
to get like some kidney maybe
yeah a you called that one anatomically
correct that was a real kidney
shot o yeah you definitely start to get
a sense for those are human anatomy
those are emotionally
draining are watching those like I just
feel
like they really kind of are I mean it's
I gotta say like towards the end you
because you can also like
so there's also another option here
that's Let's
see we can set bullet cams to reduce
minimal no x-ray quick none or
increased let's sh let's do normal I
think we're get we're doing pretty well
on normal yeah we're getting a pretty
fair
amount all right uh now I got to
actually let me search this corpse real
quick cool cool all right I think that
like that's all the dudes in this
immediate area because otherwise they
would have come running yeah the search
light operator needs to go yeah I think
I know the best way to take care of them
what is it
Sean the thing where you shoot him with
a gun okay yeah that's probably a good
way yeah that will probably do it I'm
just going to go up here do a little
Crouch do you think there's somebody
oh we got
this I think I think that's Center Mass
roughly Center Mass yeah oh no oh
through the and through the kidneys oh
go he got him through the arm yeah we
didn't see any any forearm break now is
a is a shot like that always going to
kill a man if you shoot him clean
through the Torso well you've SE I think
that yes uh in this game it will ough
you have seen me land a few shots in
this stream that just says incapacitated
yeah uh so it's not you know just cuz
you get a shot on them does not mean
that they
will uh
necessarily die especially if you're not
you know kill cam
it yeah Sniper Elite is getting a little
bold here he's just out he's a straight
jogging Elite needs to take a deep
breath his BPM is at it's a little high
right now it's at 80 so now all we need
to do is get into a power
Crouch run along for a little while
that's sure to bring down your your your
old BPM
yeah you shoot that
radio that
phonogram did it bleed I think it bled
and then
went a oh
[__] that dude come from where that turd
come from he's like who shot M A
phonogram
damn oh wow that was surprising where
was he he was on patrol or something he
was yeah where were you before dur when
I was making a hash of all your friends
I think he was out like pooping in the
bushes or something and he came back and
he's like
vas we turned off some music all right
it's it's saying that I need to disable
the search light so maybe I should just
shoot it yeah am I going to get a zoom a
tight on bullet cam on SE on search
light nope oh but I am going to alert
like three other dudes oh watch out for
that dude that dud that dude is coming
in hot and
Angy that guyy real Angry does he know
that I blew up his
phonogram he
might remember when you shot that uh
that radio and it bled yeah the the
miraculous bleeding radio yeah that was
pretty cool yeah they spoke of that for
years to come on the African
front so many dudes to
shoot
all
right but I'm so yeah see it's the the
the triangle that says my distance to my
nearest to the nearest dude that gu
that's what's going to I think that
means if I fire they'll be able to hone
in on me real quick but if I'm outside
that range then they won't be able to
you know figure out where I'm at yeah is
there a sniper perch around here
yeah back here and uh shoot a bunch more
dudes yeah you got this there's a
dude can I go prone in these
bushes
oh
oh shoot him again where is he I can't
there all right no I don't think I got
him little sloppy but bleed out kill he
bled out yeah all right there you go
sometimes relocation oh crap whoa whoa
where are those shots coming
from what are you where are you shooting
what happened to my target shooting at
the
Rock I was definitely shooting that
rock
Rick working I got to get out maybe
don't shoot the rocks so much here we go
yeah yeah take that you kick the [__]
out of that I'm out of here that
nondescript piece of
Machinery I need some bandages
yeah nope that's not a bandage I pressed
the wrong
button on the plus side you really gave
that rock a what for you think they're
going to follow me all the way over here
cuz I can also put a land mine down yeah
yeah that dude is totally following
you yeah I like this this is Gorilla
Warfare Sniper Elite really learned a
thing or two when he became an elite
mercenary he's not a mercenary no man
he's a he's an enlisted man he's an
enlisted
man I think they blew up my land mine
with a
grenade he's an elite OSS sniper his
name is name is Carl
Fairburn oh yeah don't chase me you get
it in the whatever part of you that was
all
right cool I unlocked a
Luger and also and the land mine that
means I can customize my load out with
that stuff
now presumably all right yeah relocation
successful I can now start a new life
over here with my family
okay okay you're good you are good maybe
I should stop sprinting no it's fine is
that what you're saying I mean it's a
good idea to stop sprinting got to get a
good sweat going on before you go into
murder
territory see this
guy oh yeah watch
this
through there
yeah wrong place wrong time
sucker there another dude yeah that
guy's that guy's asking for behind some
cover though I don't have a good angle
on him nope he is well behind wall he is
hunkered
down are you going to De Hunker buddy
oh he de
hunkered oh nope I pressed the wrong
button you just wounded that Manis what
are you even doing get your head in the
game Sniper Le I panicked
oh even the most elite of snipers
sometimes just commits the occasional
misstep yeah that was definitely a
misstep it's all right it's all right
but you it's fine but you you just have
to remember you are Sniper Elite there's
a reason they sent you in for this job
you're the one who can get things done
what's my name Sniper Elite Sniper Elite
that's right I can I can TCB over here
yeah you got to TCB this
situation that guy's really chapping my
buttons yeah
that guy's getting your goat and you
need to get it back from him listen I
understand you have my goat sir please
may I repossess that goat from
you the goat is valuable to me and has
great sentimental
value well Rod this dude he is going to
be well
roded that only sounds a little bit you
know
what
yeah
okay you got two new well rods to use oh
watch out guy on the left guy on the
left
[__] bad bad bad bad decision yikes wow
Sniper Elite run oh Sniper Elite wow
that wasn't that was frankly
embarrassing look at that oh man that's
not I'm I got to go away from here
situational awareness sniper Le that was
I got so mad at the men with my goat
head you got you you had laser focus on
that guy to the point where you forgot
about the guy on the left yeah this is
you guys are learning a thing or two
about but on the side and don'ts this is
a pretty sick sniper perch I feel like
you might be able to kill old what's his
name over here old surprise it's me yeah
yeah okay I see he's going to pop he's
going to pop either up or to the right
and when he does I think it's going to
be there in the window yeah I bet you I
bet you anything is going to pop his
head through that
window you just got to wait him
out this is what we trained for sitting
still don't you have any not doing crap
can you pop some diazapam or something
really lower your heart rate No but I if
I hadn't shot that phonogram
sonogram
telegram if I hadn't shot that music
player I could put on some easy
listening and I'd be
fine this is this is okay yeah this is a
good this is a good perch in worse
places to be like directly in a dude's
face oh see see all right he's just
taking what he doesn't realize will be
the last drink of his life before you
shoot his dick
off here it comes I think that was a
pretty OD
Target oh
oh do you like how his legs kind of like
go
inward oh we're up to four we got four
You' got four testicle shots thanks for
getting that counter going guys now I
will say it's always a testicle shot it
never says dick shot right I don't think
there's dicks in this game are you sure
is that part of like the M rating is I
think that yeah the difference between
an M rating and an AO rating is the
presence of Dick shots yeah okay that
makes sense I bet I bet there's some
enterprising modders out there oh I'm
sure who could like mod wangs into this
game
yeah Steam Workshop what am I tagging a
truck to tag a truck got no crew where's
the dude who's like 40 meters from me
though that bleeding
phonogram that was fun the source of all
your problems that was pretty bad uh the
day the music died was pretty was pretty
bad for old sniper
El but been dealing with the kic Fallout
of that for a while Sniper Elite with
his abundance of medical packs and
frankly ridiculous amount of ammunition
I think he's going to pull through I
want this guy to walk on the other side
of a
wall this be my longest di what
oh
there you go oh wow got that that was a
last ditch effort but it's going to hit
Pay Dirt or pay femur pay femur wow oh
you just barely missed his dangle bits
but got a good glimpse of them by like
maybe an inch and a
half so many dudes you have killed
frankly literally dozens of dudes I'm
getting so impatient you killed is it
can you go like pure stealth and not
kill anybody no or does that violate the
most basic tenant of Sniper Elite which
is that he's a sniper which is that he
kills people he's not sneaker Elite no
he's a he's not killing machine take
only pictures leave only
Footprints he will kill some
dudes but we got a we got a job to
finish all
right our producers are telling us that
we can wrap up if we want cuz we've hit
the one hour marker but cuz we've hit
the requisite four testicle shots but
you've got a job to finish Chris I do I
feel responsible
here yeah that was sick I C sick UPS man
that was
sick that one's going in the Highlight
Reel that time that I jumped over a
ledge that was good that was pretty
baller that was good that's part of what
makes him Sniper Elite and not basic
sniper guy yeah no one wants to play as
basic sniper guy you can't jump over a
some some short ledge
yeah all right your uh your officer is
right over there also other officers
right over there
isoss the way no I actually see I don't
have a vision Pi on the move oh look
that that's just some I bet you could
shoot that guy in his uh in his heart
maybe I bet you yeah you could take that
guy out all right I'm going to do it all
right time for Sniper El to do what he
does
best just bulk
murder is that one going to clip the
tree I think I threaded the needle on
that one seems like it might
yeah one lung double lung double lung
maybe not quite double lung yeah PR
meditated points pretty good
premeditated yeah as opposed to oh God
this dude's in my face I better shoot
him yeah that dude had no idea you were
there so I think you got premeditated
points every time I fire this Commander
just runs around while willy-nilly
oh yeah
oh that was sick you guys like a little
parkour I know what I know what the
audience
likes parkour Sniper Elite jumping
around oh this guy doesn't realize the
mistake he's making by walking around
what am I even see Willy Milly all right
get over to this guy yeah this guy you
got to go for him first
oh get the get right here I'm just I'm
going to create a Giant Shadow of myself
and spook half the guys away yeah
yeah yeah you guys are officers have
Keener sight than the rank and
file shoot that radio I mean I I don't
even know what that thing is all right
first off can you go oh
gosh I've started a small fire nope no
no okay okay nice
work just a small fire nothing to worry
about a
small nothing that Sniper Elite hasn't
handled before Oh I didn't realize that
other guy was the officer
oh oh yeah no come on no oh no it's a
leg
no wow oh that one was at speed
right in your commissioned testies oh my
god
oh I think this is going to be like a
jaw we haven't seen a jaw
yet oh bad angle for the jaw that was a
jugular
shot oh yeah that was definitely Ace
shot premeditated
relocated who saw me who is even around
to see things that alarms
me probably some dudes up here oh yeah
pull out the old MP
40 this might be the sniper perch F you
got the job done ain't no thing CRA
iar you going to make him run for it
he's like right down there
maybe that's just a box oh okay
sometimes I get oh I see a dude
yeah destroying those trucks damag their
supply lines what don't get greedy whoa
jerks come from oh
jerk Town USA over there did some jerk
party just let out
yeah happy hour for jerks is over now
all these drunk jerks are just walking
around with
guns but I still think there's a dude
like right around here what is that oh
that's my last yeah so I bet somebody is
trying to visit your last known location
oh yeah that
dude oh shot the oh there's a dude to
his right
coming up got to well Rod that
guy go for
the nope should have gone for the should
have gone for the old MP is that like a
bolt action well Rod or something yeah
thing sucks I told you yeah you were in
line that thing does kind of suck that's
a little baby gun you'd give to a
baby I hope that bounces a little
further
oh that was sloppy a
nuts all right
uher sight than the rank and file all
right we're back here what do you think
Sean should we try for a few more shots
or should we uh this is a good time to
wrap it up I I'm I'm committed I'm
committed to this you're committed all
right this guy is going
to oh no all right undo relax
Zoom how they can't see me
here oh he's got a binocular I'm going
to have to shoot him in the
kneecap oh there that's going to hit
somewhere that's a wild card you shot
him in his gun
hand
oh oh nice that's a that's a just going
to where no idea where's it
going right in the old rotator cuff
kidney that guy's never going to play
baseball ever again oh he had such a
bright future back in the baseball
loving country of
Germany what oh I made that guy do a
break dance move yeah you did that was
pretty
good right you going to go get the Intel
from the officer I need to make sure
that these Jag holes aren't coming up on
me again if anything they're going to
come up to the
left that's like this way is where
they're going to they can't even get up
here this is exactly where they came up
last time no they came up from down
there before and I just failed to kill
them with well
Rod freaking well rod there's nothing
Well Rod about that last
altercation oh there you go well Rod
that dude oh nice rock shooting God damn
it all right I'm going to call
Shenanigans on that one happened last
time I'm calling shenanigans on you had
a good angle you had a good clean angle
see what happens
buddy there another one probably yeah
that was definitely some
Shenanigans Now 51 m is apparently where
the next dude is all right go search
that dead body also a bunch of
dead standing by
explosives that dude he's not even
wearing a shirt he's just got a tank top
on come on he was hanging out at the
jerk
party all right I think now's your
chance to shoot that guy in his uh you
know what yeah all right here we go
let's go prone
here this is going to be a come
on
oh I mean that's a I feel like that's a
no I'm not even going to watch this one
I'm not going to watch it oh it y it was
right on the money a is it over it's
over is over yep you can look I are his
testicles still bleeding no okay I'm
going to make someone else's testicles
bleed now or maybe just this of them in
there you could go for a
twofer get real close overlap each other
through some failure of
communication
oh no I moved at the last second
oh no unsure that was where that hit you
oh there's a
dude are you y come good old number
15 no that's
terrible all right I think he'll bleed
out you don't really
okay no now when you shoot an
incapacitated man I'm getting counter
snipped is it like you're putting him
out of his misery or you want to
guarantee that he doesn't get revived I
kind I don't know actually I was put I
was wanting to guarantee the kill but I
don't know he was using a dead body for
cover oh come on I didn't hit any ribs
that was a low profile kidney shot Low
Pro oh see yeah oh
what
oh my goodness you guys now they're both
incapacitated yeah no this is what the
evil snipers do now you got to shoot
them in the junk while he's got to wait
until someone else comes to try to
revive those
suckers uh uh this is the oldest trick
in the book you wound one target lure
the other one over and shoot the second
guy yeah no I don't think anyone's going
to be so so
crash he's way back there some rocks
now's your chance to make a make a
beline for that Intel here we go got
this I'm going to I need some bandage I
need a bandage real quick I don't think
I can go down the other way can't like
just jump off that
ledge Sniper Elite is like real good at
some small
jumps but I don't think he does oh your
dude is walking over oh is he checking
it
out uh oh yeah no Sniper Elite did not
play that and that little that thing got
ruined all right yeah picked up some 100
more
bullets never have too many on down here
no problem no cares in the world grab
this
intelligence it's going to be a sheet of
paper that says be on the lookout for
man shooting people in the dicks it's
just the same memo three times maybe an
American Soldier not sure awaiting on
word from
Berlin oh yeah learning about that which
you
know would be cool if I wasn't just on
ad
Mission I think I can just hit the's
head there you
go go go gadget skull cracker that was
execution
Style
all right I think that was the last dude
in
this time to learn some
things great they don't like that guy
all right these are all op right
sabotage this
generator yeah this is all the all these
are
optional I can it but it'll like like so
sabotaging the generator here would
create noise yeah don't worry about
baffling but since I've already like
murdered all these guys mantle over this
that's probably not a bad
idea there you go and you said Sniper
Elite couldn't drop down onto things I
did I you know what I underestimated
Sniper Elite landmines all
right oh is a vehicle going to show up
hell
no focus on the FOC eyes on the prize
look put a thing
here dude is behind all those rocks over
there coming into a new
area probably can some dudes going to be
I feel like you
oh there's an amount of dudes this is a
real dude
party oh yeah CH a grenade at him
from downtown that's
far boom triple kill that was clean that
was nice that was clean I feel real real
good about that I feel like that was
pretty Elite yeah that Sniper Elite
doing his
elitist I am a sniper
elitist they call you the elitist sniper
they call sniper elitist that's what
they should call
it just it's just a game of you watching
tapes of other snipers getting kills and
being
like not as good as
me sniper
elst SP feel like it just said one meter
but maybe that's I don't know feel like
might
be some German sleeping in a cave
there's always a German pooping in the
bushes somewhere that's the that's a
thing that you got to watch out for
there's any takeaways from this
it's that's what happened when the when
you shot that phonogram looks like the
Germans are shifting explosives in those
crates watch out the crates have
explosives in them meral meral good
shoot them machines wow there's a German
a German at a gun in placement waiting
to get his what is he he's looking
straight up into the sky is he yeah oh
no no he's he's focused on this truck
he he doesn't not that is a man who does
not trust a truck he's got he's got his
eyes fixed firmly on that truck waiting
for that truck to turn just waiting for
it to make a move
yeah all right he questions that truck's
dedication to the
Reich oh what a terrible shot it's
fine all right all right I'm going to
relocate across brazenly across this
road oh hello watch out for that dude
okay
nope thing is you don't really have to
concern yourself with that dude you
you're heading across this Lagoon sneak
around the Lagoon here and hopefully
not fine it's fine that's yesterday's
news yeah I just want to you know keep
taging oh yeah tagging him is a good
idea then they're going to flank the
crap out of me once I start shooting
people over here or maybe not that's
just going to go poop in the bushes
those dudes are always pooping in the
bushes I don't know if you've had food
in whatever region you don't know afria
I mean this looks like you know there's
eating coconuts all day you're going to
[__] yourself
silly back here so I can murder you
please I that dude all
right I'm feel pretty confident those
are the only two guys in in that area so
if you just really charge in go for the
combo attack I think you'll be just fine
yeah the linked attack right yeah yeah
combo attack that's that's definitely
what a sniper can do combo attack all
right what is that what are you doing oh
he's pooping in the bushes got body
guard watching him this guy's smoking
and just everything looks fine sir a
look at that amateur there's he just put
his hand in it he just put his hand
right in it that's some good pooping sir
definitely snipers in the bushes out
there a great job sir all right yep yeah
no it's a big one sir I see it one looks
great sir if I could urge you to pinch
it off we have some business to attend
to do do you want to hit off this
it's it's the good stuff oh man he had
to reposition his weight that's how
serious that one was oh my goodness all
right I'm going to throw a rock and try
to line these guys up yeah you're going
for the two I like your
style know going to try to hit him on
the
Rock no
stay they he is just going at
it he can't stop he is all jammed
up I chucking rock on his head I think I
just hit him on the head oh that dude
well on the plus side you did him a
favor the other guy is totally
unperturbed yeah other dud he is still
hitting that real hard all right you got
you're you're luring him over which one
are you going to shoot you going to wait
for them to line
up going to get a better angle oh oh
double NAD double dick shot to finish
the
life okay damn it now that I've tasted
the potential I can't not try it again
got to go you got to get the perfect
sight line on these guys get that double
dick shot
oh oh oh
oh all right so he's going to walk to
the right you need to move to the
left I think I need to Target the guys
guy behind
him oh
closer no no no okay
okay come on watch out for that no it's
going to be
okay and now
oh damn it there you go damn it you know
what it's all right you you know I tried
it just flew too close to the Sun on
that
one um so you have some some
buddies
just
pretty good now there's a giant
earthquake oh wow that's not going to
draw anybody over so now there's your
chance to just run straight into it yeah
this is no problem you're fine wow
everything's exploding over there
whatever happened there is in the past
you need to just run up and grab that
intelligence look a
body I'm searching all the bodies all
right great cool I got the info yeah
Mission no I don't no I think that's no
I think that's like we there's more
dudes for you to kill there's a final
officer son of
a d son of a
d need to go over here anymore got you
guys thanks for nothing oh wait look at
I want to see how their bodies are
slumped e see how they are in their
final Embrace this
guy oh that dick is right yeah this guy
is getting his ear that's perfect that's
perfect that is just a beautiful oh wow
he's not this man is made of wood that's
all that's all you see the wood grain on
his face yeah yeah yeah this wooden man
is being humped by this leopard
human you killed Pinocchio oh God
jepetto jepetto served a turn as a
German
Commander oh gosh you should just shoot
the engine on that truck that truck
marked did I Mark that truck by accident
think so there's no one inside it on
Mark I'm only interested in trucks with
testicles inside
them what if they have a pair of truck
nuts hanging off the
B then I will shoot the truck nuts oh my
goodness if you guys uh aren't familiar
with truck nuts or maybe you live in a
part of the world where truck nuts are
not popular do yourself a favor Google
truck nuts Google truck nuts yeah
broaden your cultural Horizons you're
definitely not going to become
immediately dis usted you won't be
revolted by American culture in any way
yeah not not in the
slightest oh
delightful you go I just need to
say all right did you hear that the the
controller makes a reloading
noise nice I'm going to you going for
the Mele Hill yeah I'm going to going
for the
M although this guy's kind of standing
awkwardly near this thing I'm not sure
if I'm maybe should just well R him I
think I'm not going to even mess around
here and just well
roded wow that was execution style you
were just right up in his
business I was in his business his
business oh and the twitch chat has
discovered truck nuts truck
nuts well they let you led them there SE
did I did and you know I think they can
only thank
you
God oh all right is that is that a
request do you need more nutsh shots is
that what you're you're like reduced to
thinking longingly about truck nuts no
no no no no I think we're doing okay
here oh this guy with his stupid
cover stupid he's got a buddy back there
watch out a I think his buddy is far
enough away like lie down over here and
shoot all these guys
yeah over
there
theud going to shoot that dude I'm going
try to tag this guy want to get my tags
in all my tags in a row oh you should
shoot that Barrel I first I really need
to shoot the guy who is machine gun go
you spot that guy where is that a dude
in the little corner there this or is
that just Shadow sorry I thought that
was a dude that's fine I appreciate your
dude Dar dude Dar my dude Dar is off
your dudar is a little off you got some
options better to have ambitious dude
Dar than poor dude Dar this is a really
uh terribly exposed Place yeah so you
are the second you fire your gun I'm
going to at least back up so that I can
duck behind this wall real quick yeah
it's probably how not to Sniper
Elite right in his shapely cheekbones
look at that right in his my guess fine
Aran
cheekbones that was the boniest one yet
I think that was real bony all right now
shoot that
Barrel double kill see I know what's up
now that guy this guy on the Run yeah
him on the run right in the
junk oh oh do you want to get officer
now or this guy oh officer somebody's
going to revive that
dude be aware I think it's this guy I
think he's trying to do it right now not
today junior oh what if I shoot the part
of your brain that knows about
medicine
boom now what I've got to do is just the
wound oh I'm just I don't know what to
do now I can I can say the alphabet
still the officer is by
himself he's see I think he's
spooked I think he's a little bit
spooked is he spooked from all the
horrible murder oh dude on the
left where did that guy come from where
did they all come from oh is he
going oh no I'm out of
ammo you're out of sniper ammo no I my
clip was empty okay I was going to say
made like a little uh I tried to fire
and it made like a little clink noise
watch out for the guy on the right I
think he's charging at you is he maybe
not I can do the under truck shot under
truck I think you're just going to hit
that
truck all right hope that truck doesn't
blow up in my face that'll
be oh oh oh oh double
shot
oh
what Why didn't it do the double oh left
to the left left where behind that truck
left left left right there oh God the
man who's shooting at you is the guy
okay there you
go yeah I can oh god oh they've got
their own Sniper
Elite um oh
God can I go down this well that seems
like a bad idea they're going to
throw and without any arms you just kind
of slid into that
well where where are the bad
guys I want to see if there's one by
that gun in placement there is I just
saw his stupid little head oh Bo oh man
did you see how close I was to that
barrel of explosives worth it there's
literally a barel explosive right in my
face and it literally says oong on it
oh can you shoot the engine on that
truck did you get the guy oh yeah yeah
you
did that'll learn him to hide behind
some
truck stay away from trucks kids they're
getting shot by sniper
Elites all right Sniper Elite he's on a
roll here you've got quite a kill combo
I still think there's another dude as
evidenced by by that red icon yeah
there's definitely a dude uh it's not
the commander the officer's a little
further
away so there he is
oh I I was going to shoot but then I
pressed the wrong button so now I'm
going to Recons so he's just hanging out
he's standing up he's like it everything
seems totally
fine that was a quick shot oh wow that
was a twitch testy shot that I think
that reflects the skill that you've
developed at shooting men's testicles
off you know I just it used to take me a
long time to line one of these shots up
that's second nature now is
that come
on from
down this one's going to be a kidney I'm
going
long
intestines what the difference look at
that the intestines always make them
jump
make them spring into the air all right
I'm feeling pretty cocky right now man
those things they really do just kind of
like they're
bracing yeah I feel like I've lived a
thousand
lifetimes in this hour and a half stream
this long live stream of snip all all
right are there any any Jerry's left I
don't know I'm literally just jogging
down the way oh there's totally one
right
there what's going on what is happening
over here something seems not right I
think you know where to
go a all right Batman's testicles will
live to see another
day where are you where are you
Gerald through the window oh that would
have been
good tag him or I untagged him
someone heard sound I bet you should run
up
yeah bad guy up
here you're
good he's going to come back out
eventually oh there he is I
see
Dam
ah fine it's fine I think I saw another
one is there another guy I mean I was
just making a real lot of noise let's
just let's just Chuck some rocks out
here and just to see we go that's sniper
lead at his
best anybody out there anybody out
anybody just huging rocks from a huge
platform yeah there is another dude it
said what was that what was
that but where is
he no
come out come out wherever you are it's
worth pointing out that this is your
last known location right
here did he spot me I don't know if he
did you got to get him when he walks
out I am not getting these nut shots man
now's your chance go for the final nut
shot I don't know if it'll do it stand
up is he dead you know where to aim you
know where he died dang
it bled out he died while out bled out
before I
could all right Rob of his I think now
you just genital Integrity straight to
the
Intel just chucking more rocks I think
You' you've taken out all the Jerry's I
feel like I pretty well de Jered this
joint pick up the
body
major
alesandro mission
accomplished what
what Ambush and kill the general before
he leaves I should use the time to
prepare I wasn't that last one the new
Final objective yes now this is your new
Final objective yes okay all right
General I mean we made it this far I'll
put a land mine right here just in
case half track destroyed oh he R land
mine
yes always one step ahead oh suck on
that General woo Victory the Corp that
was great my reward two
words project Zer
project project Zoidberg
oh that was rich wonder wall wait wonder
wall your my wonder wall yeah Chris that
was great what would you say in this
entire chart where would you say your
most common shot was well we did get a
lot of nines I feel like that's the lung
Zone yeah uh and a fair and Nines in the
head as well you know but uh ultimately
at the end of day we we had a pretty
regular steady supply 15s a lot of 15s
right there no seven oh fantastic thank
you guys uh for watching Sean thanks for
bearing with me this that was something
I remembered when from reviewing it last
time is like they get a those shots get
a little intense so you you could toggle
them but uh certainly do oh man good
stuff Sniper Elite 3 out next week or
out next week or tomorrow if you're in
Europe tomorrow in Europe
yeah Pardon Me Chris what do we have
coming up on the Gamespot live docket on
the Gamespot live docket yeah I don't
know we'll just wait for them to holler
at us from the back and tell us but uh
tomorrow what don't know we don't know
Mysteries there's always Monday which uh
you can watch Peter Brown's meab bit
Yeah Chris wat old games with Peter
Brown and multiplayer games with me
multiple players on Monday uh but until
then enjoy watching World Cup games uh
have fun not getting shot in any part of
you I hope hopefully thanks for watching
folks have a good one see you later
goodbye